Mudmen bog Devils those are just the
most pleasant names our fellow
northerners have for us the chronic men
who live in the swamps of the neck
because we do not live in castles like
them because we do not farm like them
because we are not tall or rich like
them but through our veins flows the
same blood of the first men and at times
may be something more we still live much
as they did on floating islands in
houses of thatch and woven reeds we fish
hunt and tell our children of our heroes
the knight of the Laughing tree who
fought in a year of the full spring the
last Marsh king who challenged the
Starks and lost his crown and his
daughter and other stories older still
since lost to the world the neck was not
always a swamp in the dawn age it was as
dry and fertile as the rest of the North
but during the war with the first men
the children of the forest brought down
the hammer of waters on the neck trying
to break Westeros in two when the waters
finally receded they left the bogs and
swamps we know today many of the first
men decided to fight on but my ancestors
wisely chose to heed the children's
power and advance no father they beat
their swords into frog Spears and fish
hooks and settle the land forever
devastated by the folly of war unlike
the rest of Westeros we keep no
Garrison's and raise no soldiers for
petty spats with our neighbors our land
protects its own
an outsider will find in a neck in
endless morass of suckholes quicksands
and green grass that looked solid to the
unwary eye but turns to water the
instant you tread on it if you're lucky
enough to be armored you'll only drown
inside your own steel if you're not you
get to meet what swims in that water
serpents and monstrous lizard lions with
teeth like daggers and never enough to
eat
don't worry only your horse will live
long enough to feel their poisons
burning through it busy summer I'll
survive all this you may find that a
well-placed dart can be as deadly as any
blade not that you'll see us blowing it
your way since the fall of the last
Marsh King House Reed has ruled the neck
beneath the banner of a black lizard
lion from a gray green field we are not
wealthy powerful or known even to our
own countrymen our home greywater watch
is no Castle you've ever seen and seeing
it once does not mean you'll ever find
it again for greywater watch moves many
would-be conquerors have died trying to
find us with war all around and our
stock lord besieged on all sides many
more will doubtless soon try it will
look at us on a map and see a
stranglehold for the north and they will
forget that the sea itself once entered
the neck and not all of it returned